form for democracy
Disqualifies our independent media
indicate that
journalists mine our society
those are very far-reaching statements
what this is about
and I hear that many colleagues say
is that words are not innocent
that we should think carefully about words
and disqualify it
of our journalists who do their work independently
that has consequences
we can't look away from that
here from lakes madam l e b
l e b
totally contradicts himself by talking about our
journalists who are independent
it's your journalists not ours
and they are not independent at all
because they are in charge
when we talk about the mpo of 1 d 66 boss
which is paid by the government
thus depends on the government
and the supposedly independent
journalists in the Netherlands
they have also totally sold their souls
the editor-in-chief of the Volkskrant has called for
to speak with one mouth in the corona crisis
and follow the line of the rvm
that has nothing to do with it anymore
control power
then you are 1 applause machine of power
from the cabinet
pressure has been exerted
on the telegraph for not too much
to criticize the RVM
so what independent media are you talking about
actually there are only 1 number
1 pair of independent journalistic
platforms in the Netherlands at the moment
that's not the most of media
and those platforms have to do
threats and violence with aggression
and I'll get to that in a moment